بالفعل زين ودعنا فقط نشير الى هذا الخبر
الذي اوردته وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه
قبل قليل عن مراقب الدوله في اسرائيل وهي
مؤسسه مهمه في مراقبه عمل السلطه
التنفيذيه في اسرائيل الذي يقول بانه
سيفتح تحقيقا فيما سماها الاخفاقات التي
سبقت احداث السابع من اكتوبر الماضي ومتى
وما تلى ذلك من اخفاقات ايضا على مستوى
الوزارات الحكوميه واشار بانه لن يستثني
من ذلك حقيقه في المسؤوليه الشخصيه عن
الاخفاقات في احداث السابع من اكتوبر سواء
كان ذلك على المستويات السياسيه
والعسكريه وكذلك المدنيه منها هذا خبر في
غايه الاهميه طبعا هو لا ياتي مكان تشكيل
لجنه تحقيق رسميه تكون لها انياب في تقديم
المسؤولين عن هذه الاخفاقات حتى الى
المحاكمه او تقديم ملفات جنائيه ضدهم لكن
هذه مؤسسه مهمه في اسرائيل في عمليه مراق
را قبه السلطه التنفيذيه والسلطه
التشريعيه في اسرائيل ولهذه التقارير التي
يضعها مراقب الدوله قد تكون ايضا اساسا
لتحقيقات جنائيه في المستقبل لذلك هذا
الاعلان هو على قدر كبير من من الاهميه في
خضم هذه العمليه العسكريه المتواصله في
داخل قطاع غزه وواضح بان اعداد القتلى
والجرحى زين في صفوف الجيش الاسرائيلي
يعكس بطبيعه الحال ضراوه وشراسه الم معارك
التي تجري في داخل قطاع غزه سواء في
المناطق الشماليه او الوسطى او الجنوبيه
ثلاثه من الضباط والجنود الذين اعلن عن
مقتلهم هذا اليوم قتلوا في معارك شمال
قطاع غزه وهذا يعني بان المعارك على اشدها
والمعارك كانت ضاريه يوم امس وكنا شهودا
عليها في مختلف الاحياء في مدينه غزه ليس
فقط في الاحياء التي بدا الجيش الاسرائيلي
العمل فيها كما قال في الايام الاخيره وهي
حيي الدرج التفاح انما بيانات الجيش
الاسرائيلي تؤكد على ان الجيش الاسرائيلي
ما زال يواجه مقاومه حتى في حي الشجاعيه
هذا الحي الذي قال بانه يسيطر عليه ناريا
وعمليا في الايام الماضيه حيث قال بانه
استهدف مجموعه من المقاومين الفلسطينيين
في الحي من خلال قصفهم باحدى الطائرات
المقاتله التي تم استدعائها الى الحي ل
توجيه هذه الضربه لهذه المجموعه من
المقاتلين لكن من ناحيه اخرى بالاضافه الى
كل احياء مدينه غزه التي تشتعل فيها بين
الحين والاخر المواجهات هنالك الان قصف
شديد يتركز ايضا على المناطق الوسطى لقطاع
غزه ونحن نتحدث عن المناطق التي تقع ما
بين جحر الديك والمغر وبين مخيمي البريج
والنصيرات هذه المناطق تشهد في الساعات
الاخيره قصفا مدفعيا شديدا وكذلك غارات
جويه عنيفه جحر ال تعرض هذا الصباح لغار
جويه وكذلك المناطق الواقعه في عمق منطقه
قطاع غزه في تلك المناطق وهي المغرا
والاطراف الشماليه ل النصيرات اي واضح بان
الجيش الاسرائيلي يركز من عملياته
العسكريه الان في منطقه جحر الديك في
البريج وفي نصيرات وفي هذه المواقع تحديدا
بعد ان انتقلت الفرقه 6 التي بدات عمليه
الاجتياح البري في اقصى المناطق الشماليه
لقطاع غزه في بيت حنون في بيت لاهيا الان
هذه الفرقه اي بعد ان قامت في العمليه
العسكريه في الشجاعيه واشتركت في القتال
هناك بدات تتوجه جنوبا الى منطقه جحر
الديك ومن هناك تناور ايضا للدخول الى
البريج والى الصراط وغيرها من المناطق في
وسط قطاع غزه واضح بان الجيش الاسرائيلي
يوسع من عملياته العسكريه في تلك ال
المنطقه وا يعني نهج العمليات العسكريه لا
يختلف كثيرا زين ح حقيقه عن ما شاهدناه في
المناطق الشماليه لقطاع غزه وفي احياء
مدينه غزه قصف مدفعي شديد غارات جويه
شديده واشتباكات بين الحين والاخر ايضا
بالاسلحه الرشاشه الثقيله هذا يشير الى
حده القتال الى دراوه القتال واان الجيش
الاسرائيلي ما زال يحاول ان يسيطر على هذه
المناطق وتحديدا الوصول او محاوله الوصول
على الاقل الى شبكات الانفاق والى فتوحات
الانفاق التي ما زالت تك الجيش الاسرائيلي
الخسائر الاكبر وما زالت تؤرق حقيقه
القوات البريه العامله على الارض